[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 10
février merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 78 le journal
votre journal d'actualité chaque jour
entouré de nos invités mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition prononciation la gare
de versaill chantier fait po neu débuté
en avril 2014 ses travaux devrai
améliorer le qu des voyageurs une
deuxème passerelle est déjà sortie de
terre retour sur ce chantier de grand
ampleur et comment gérer les risques
quotidiens les accidents domestiques
mais aussi les risques professionnels
ces accidents de la vie courante qui
entraînent près de 20000 décès par an en
France les réponses de notre invité
Benoît noble manager en prévention des
risques et enfin à rouiller des élèves
du collège Saint- théresse CC au
doublage de films ou de dessins animés
un atelier unique sur le territoire que
nous nous vous ferons découvrir et à 50
ans ni vin une cinquantaine de médecins
généralistes appliquent désormais des
dépassements pour exigences
particulières du patient en dehors des
plages horaires de 9h à 17h un mouvement
qui s'apparente au 35h en réponse au
projet de loi de santé que les médecins
condamnent on écoute tout de suite le
docteur eekier médecin généralisteelle
en cours il nous dit souvent que on est
des des salariés de la sécurité sociale
on a dit ben si on est des salariés de
la sécurité sociale à ce moment-là on
travaille 35 cur c'est pour ça qu'on on
va prendre par exemple un dépassement
pour exigen particulières mais qu'on ne
prend pas au patients qui sont qui ont
la CMU ou le l'aide médicale d'État ou
l'assurance complémentaire santé ou qui
sont en accident de travail si le
patient a une mutuelle et ben on on
prendra on prendra 2 € on peut prendre
10 € si c'est des gens qu'on qu'on sait
qu'ils ont une très bonne mutuelle voilà
par exemple bon et et les gens qui n'ont
pas de mutuelle enfin c'est c'est plus
rare mais c'est vrai que des chôeurs
peuvent très bien ne pas avoir de mutuel
et ben on leur prendra rien évidemment
et Santz toujours le Conseil
départemental et la direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale des ivines ont participé hier
à une journée de rencontre et d'échang
sur le thème de l'élève à l'enfant
prévenir éduquer protéger ensemble au
lycée hôtelier de guilloncour les deux
parties travaillent conjointement depuis
décembre 2014 sur l'accompagnement des
familles et des enfants du département
les plus fragile ainsi qu'au
développement de la politique de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
dans le cadre de leur mission respective
un moyen de favoriser la connaissance
mutuelle entre professionnels de
dynamiser ce partenariat et aussi de
mettre en place une pr une convention
cadre plus d'explications au micro de
Fanny Bourdillon on voudrait vraiment
que notre politique de de prévention et
protection de l'enfance soit moins
stigmatisante à l'égard des familles et
que les familles puissent confprendre
qu'on est là pour les aider et non pas
pour les juger par rapport aux
difficultés d'un enfant donc c'était
vraiment important pour nous de faire ce
travail là ensemble avec nos partenaires
de l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
savoir comment on fait pour mieux se
connaître entre les différents
professionnels deéducation nationale qui
soi infirmier médecin psychologue ou ce
genre de de personnel et puis nos
personnels à nous que soit aussi les les
pirricultrices les les médecins la PMI
donc faire en sorte que chacun prenne
conscience de l'existence de l'autre ce
qui était pas forcément facile et puiss
puiss se dire comment on fait pour
travailler et on a mis en œuvre une
process un un une procédure qui est une
procédure originale sur laquelle on a
travaillé sur des des exemples en fait
un petit peu d'école et qui permessaiit
justement d'échanger sur ces situations
d'enfants vous l'avez sûrement remarqué
si vous empruntez pour vos déplacements
quotidiens la gare de Versailles
chantier elle est temps travaux débuté
en avril 2014 l'objectif du chantier est
d'augmenter le confort et la fluidité
des voyageurs notamment en multipliant
par deux les escaliers et les ascenseurs
deuxè Gare de l'Ouest parisien en terme
de trafic la gare de Versailles chantier
devrait être rénové et agrandi les
précisions avec Fanny Bourdillon
versailleschantier la gare n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom si elle a été
fondée en 1932 elle n'avait pas reçu de
modification significativ depuis avec
actuellement 68000 usagers par jour et
quasi 1000 trains qui passent par ce
nœud ferroviaire des travaux étaient
indispensables le trafic ben Transilien
à croire régulièrement d'année en année
on a de plus en plus de clients et on
avait de moins en moins de possibilités
pour en terme de confort d'information
voyageur et surtoutah d'évacuation de
nos clients dans de bonnes conditions
donc on a créé cette passerelle qui
vient augmenter le nombre de sorties
augmenter le nombre de services la
passerelle c'est le gros du chantier
d'une longueur d'une centaine de mètres
elle est disposée au-dessus des voies et
permettra de diviser le flux actuel des
voyageurs par deux avec un budget de 80
millions d'euros il est aussi prévu de
rénover le bâtiment historique et de
construire un bâtiment de liaison qui
comportera une quinzaine de commerces
Versailles doit être une gare signific
en île-de-fance le projet pèse 80
millions d'euros et donc c'est une gare
avec des commerces avec un haut niveau
de confort il y a une quinzaine de
commerces
restauration coiffeur petit commerce de
proximité tout un tas de de petits
commerces qui vont répondre aux attentes
de nos clients gar les travaux débutés
en avril 2014 doivent s'étaler jusqu'en
2018 mais la passerelle 2 sera mise en
service dès le 5 avril prochain et
chaque année les accidents de la vie
courante entraînent près de 20000 décès
par an en France je vous disis et en
titre la gestion du risque et donc une
nécessité pour nous en parler ce soir
Benoît noble bonsoir alors vous êtes élu
à la sécurité civile à ilencours et
manager en prévention des risques vous
animez vendredi 12 février donc à la
mairie des lcours à 19h une conférence
intitulée pour un quotidien sans risque
alors tout d'abord de quel risqu
allons-nous parler dans cette conférence
alors de très peu de risque des risques
au quotidien vous parliez des risques en
général quand on parle de risque c'est
souvent oxiogène et nos concitoyens
s'imaginent euh la tornade de
l'inondation ça nous arrive bien
évidemment il faut savoir gérer ces
événements mais entre ces événements dit
majeurs euh et les événements du
quotidien euh vous avez un ensemble de
risques auquels vous pouvez faire face
alors que va-t-on allez-y je vous en
pris j'y vais j'y viens euh donc cette
conférence comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure n'a pas de vocation oxyogène au
contraire de prévenir et informer et
sensibiliser nos concitoyens et nos
administrés sur la façon d'appréhender
tous ces petits risques que vous pouvez
avoir pour ces fameux risques au
quotidien dans la rue en pratiquant une
activité sportive mais également les
risques domestiques dont on parle très
peu qui se dérouleront par de par le
nature à votre domicile et qui
malheureusement font énormément de
victimes en France et quand je parle de
victimes je parle de mort
malheureusement aussi et beaucoup de
blessés on parle de 4500000 blessés par
an ce qui est une charge importante tant
pour la la collectivité mais également
pour les victimes il faut le savoir
alors durant cette conférence on va va
apprendre comment éviter justement ces
risques comment être plus vigilant tout
à fait nous allons aborder plusieurs
thèmes d'abord euh comprendre la notion
de différence entre le danger et le
risque alors justement quelle est cette
différence alors sans aborder la la la
façon scientifique euh et plusudique le
le le danger c'est une c'est un espace
dans lequel on va évoluer et vers lequel
on va tendre sur un risque le risque
étant une atteinte ou à votre intégrité
physique ou à vos valeurs financières ou
constructive donc l'objectif étant de
les éité et effectivement à la fin de
cette conférence après avoir pris
plusieurs exemples je viendrai sur des
fondamentaux de base comme chacun le
sait les risques le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais not notre objectif à nous en
tant qu'élu c'est d'aider la population
à en prendre conscience et àattendre
vers le risque zéro alors on pense
souvent aux accidents domestiques parce
qu'ils font beaucoup de blessés mais il
n'y a pas que ça il y a aussi les
risques professionnels et les risques en
collectivité oui alors le la galaxie des
risques si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
comporte effectivement de nombreux
risques vous avez les risques
domestiques on vient d'en parler euh les
risques quotidiens qui englobent euh les
activités extrapressionnelles et et en
dehors du domicile mais oui les risques
professionnels les accidents du travail
euh les risques sociaux les risques
financiers euh je pourrais vous vous
parler des risques pendant des heures
même des jours euh donc tous ces risques
sont à appréhender et savoir que une
situation donnée si on y répond
favorablement euh en ayant pris
conscience euh de des éléments qu'on
peut qu'on peut tendre vers le haut euh
on va avoir une influence sur le le
l'aspect psychologique et sur l'aspect
financier qui de toute façon ne seront
jamais pris en charge ni par les
assurances ni par la collectivité donc
c'est à chacun de se prendre en charge
et à ne pas compter sur ce maillage
exceptionnel qu'on a en France il faut
savoir que la France est l'un des pays
euh les mieux doté en matière de
sécurité civile avec un maillage de
saport pompier de SMUR ou SAMU pour le
commun des mortels sans jeux de mot
euh les associations agréées de secours
les élus les commune et on part vers un
assistana qui parfois nous fait tendre à
oublier le risque au quotidien tous ces
petits risques qui peuvent nous polluer
la vie entre guillemets et auquel on
doit pouvoir faire face avec un tout
petit peu de bon sens alors j'aimerais
qu'on revienne au risque professionnel
on s'imagine que ça concerne peut-être
des personnes qui font des métiers voilà
physiques ou endurant ça peut aussi
toucher peut-être des métiers de bureau
et est-ce que vous avez une situation
concrète peut-être à expliquer alors euh
le risque professionnel est très vague
il ne concerne vous euh comme je le
disais votre intégrité physique mais
également l'intégrité de votre
entreprise
euh un geste
anodin alors on ne parle plus de
cigarettees puisque maintenant il est
interdit de fumer dans les bureaux
depuis de nombreuses années mais des
prises électriques surchargé ça peut
être le cas chez vous aussi peuvent
déclencher un incendie dans votre
entreprise vous revenez le lendemain
main dans votre entreprise et
malheureusement vous retrouvez
Descendres et vous serez ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement au chômage
technique et tant pour l'entreprise que
pour vous-même ça aura un impact
conséquent donc c'est un un des risques
mais les risques professionnels ce sont
les les postures sur le le le le bureau
donc les ce qu'on appelle les troubles
musculos-squelettiques euh c'est la
fatigue c'est on en parle énormément en
ce moment le burnout ou le borout
puisque ce sont deux phénomènes euh un
peu différents euh ça PE pe être les
intoxications alimentaires puisque vous
faites vous bénéficiez d'une d'une
cantine ça peut être plein de choses ça
peut être les les les transmissions de
de maladie là nous sommes en période de
de grippe et de gastro-entérite chacun
sait que il vaut mieux éviter les bisous
du matin les les poignées de mains et
tant qu'à faire autant se laver les
mains et ne pas simplement se satisfaire
de de
mélange vous savez ces mélanges qu'on
vous vend en pharmacie qui vont vous
désinfecter les mains il faut d'abord se
laver les mains et ensuite se l'
désinfecté donc voyez je pourrais encore
continuer et dérouler et ce type de
risque pour l'entreprise il est valable
dans tous les domaines d'activité est-ce
qu'il y a des publics un petit peu visés
ciblés dans cette conférence peut-être
les jeunes parents ou les personnes
âgées qui sont aussi souvent victimes de
ces accidents au quotidien alors tout le
monde euh est concerné bien évidemment
plutôt les parents donc les personnes on
va dire entre 7 ans et peut-être 107 ans
euh l'espérance de vie grandissant en
France maintenant tout le monde aura une
action c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
dominau aura une action sur l'autre et
les parents sont forcément sensibles
pour leurs enfants mais les enfants
doivent peut-être l'être aussi pour
leurs grands-parents puisqu'ils vont
pouvoir avoir des petites attentions de
tous les jours qui vont leur permettre
d'éviter la chute fortuite parce que un
un tapis mal placé ou parce qu'une
rallonge traversant le le couloir donc
tout le public est concerné en France
nous sommes la lanterne rouge en matière
de sensibilisation et formation on parle
énormément des accidents de la route
donc du risquees routiers un peu moins
des risques technologiques et naturels
les risques naturels on les voit
régulièrement aux journaux télévisés
donc cou les tempêtes les avalanches et
cetera malheureusement les risques du
quotidien très peu donc il faudrait et
c'est ma mission de développer cette
sensibilisation pour que tout le monde
prenne conscience de la nécessité de la
chose alors justement vous le disiez
tout à l'heure avec 4,5 million de
recours aux urgences 500000 HP alisation
et environ 20000 descés par an les 10 et
12 millions d'accidents de la vie
courante se produitent chaque année en
France pourquoi on en parle si peu
pourquoi il n a il y a peu de prévention
finalement autour de ce problème de
société alors jeis vous en parler tout à
l'heure donc les chiffres on les connaît
pas exactement on sait que donc ça ça ça
relève des des des des établissements
publics qui font les les des comptes
mais donc on parle de 20000 morts à peu
près par an en France et de 4,5 million
d'hospitalisation alors
l'hospitalisation j'entends
l'hospitalisation d'une demi-heure parce
que un un fil pour recoudre une pie
suturer une plie ou parce que une une
hospitalisation plus lourde
hospitalisation qui peut coûter de 500 €
ou quelques centaines d'euros à
plusieurs milliers d'euros si on passe
en réanimation ou en traitement très
lourd euh
pourquoi n'agissons-nous pas pardon euh
sur cet axe je ne sais pas et c'est
justement la nature de ma mission
sensibiliser le public que le public euh
aille vers la connaissance du risque
mais les petits risques je ne parle pas
du pot de yaourt qui peut tomber de par
terre quoi que par l'effet dominaux on
peut aller vers une chute et vers une
une
hospitalisation mais que les gens
prennent conscience et prennent
conscience surtout que le le le le
système de secours en France et le
système hospitalier ne pourra pas à
vitam etternam satisfaire les les la
bobologie de chacun et chacun doit
pouvoir au minimum se prendre en charge
et faire attention à soi et aux autres
alors après votre conférence vous nous
le garantissez on va quand même limiter
les risques peut-être approcher du
risque zé au quotidien c'est l'objectif
en tout cas sensibiliser les gens euh
nos concitoyens arrêz de se dire ce
n'est pas grave je ferai appel au 18 au
17 au 15 alors j'espère que nos
auditeurs nos téléspectateurs
connaissent ces numéros en tout cas
c'est le minimum euh ne pas
systématiquement appeler les secours
mais commencer à prendre des
dispositions pour éviter ce dont je vous
ai parlé le feu de cheminée euh le les
aliments qui restent sur sur le feu
l'enfant qui va rester tout seul dans la
maison on voit des drames tous les jours
et on en entend parler tous les jours
les meubles près d'une d'une fenêtre
ouverte qui vont permettre à l'enfant de
de monter sur le meuble et
malheureusement faire une chute de
grande hauteur des exemples j'en ai mout
à vous à vous proposer l'idée c'est
justement que tout le monde se
responsabilise un petit peu arrête de se
reposer systématiquement sur la qualité
de nos secours et se prenre un petit peu
en charge merci beaucoup Benoît noble
alors je le rappelle votre conférence
donc pour un quotidien sans risque a
lieu le vendredi 12 février à 19h à la
mairie d'loncour c'est ouvert à tout le
monde tout le monde pe tout voilà tout à
fait merci à vous sans transition coup
de projecteur à présent sur capland
cette marque française a été créé en
2014 par le Francilien Enric boisur
équipe depuis cette saison l'équipe de
football américain des Templiers
deslancour et compte un distributeur
dans les Yvelines justement à Plaisir
regardez ce reportage signé Michel
les Templiers d'élencour ont un nouvel
équipementtier pour cette saison 2016
les éencourtois qui évoluent en première
division on signé un partenariat de 3
ans avec capland l'entreprise crée en
2014 veut s'imposer comme le fournisseur
officiel du sport américain dans
l'Hexagone on a adressé l'ensemble des
des sports majeurs US à savoir le
football américain en premier lieu qui
est notre notre notre raison d'être en
fait au départ le baseball le hocket sur
glace et j'espère à la fin du du du du
semestre 2016 donc second semestre 2016
le basketball français en parallèle des
tenues sportives la firme vend également
des casquettes avec les logos des
équipes françaises porter la casquette
de sa ville sielle est aussi belle
qu'une casquette nuera
ou une casquette écrit New York dessus
je je suis prêt à faire le Paris que
porter une casquette de sa villeelle est
très très belle c'est c'est c'est pas
plus lait ou c'est pas c'est bien
meilleur que de porter une casquette
d'une ville étrangè ou donc je crois que
les gens sont prêts sur le terrain les
footballeurs d'élancour ont pu tester
leur nouveau maillot à l'occasion de la
réception des gladiateurs de la queambri
lors de la première journée du
championnat la marque compte 11 réseaux
de distribution dans les ivelines la
société 417 feet situé dans la zone
d'activité la chîne à Plaisir vend des
casquettes capland dans le secteur c'est
la casquette des Templiers qui se vend
le plus on a beaucoup de joueurs des
Templiers qui passent acheter leurs
casquettes je dirais que pour l'instant
on a vendu une trentaine de casquettes
mais
approximativement après les Templiers
l'entreprise CAPL devrait également
signer un partenariat avec l'équipe de
baseball des coupgard de montig
breneux et comme chaque mercredi nous
allons maintenant parler d'environnement
et de développement durable avec la
chronique de Mélanie poquet bonsoir
Mélanie bonsoir floral alors cette
semaine nous allons voir les liens entre
les gaz à effet de serre et nos
habitudes alimentaires alors l'effet de
serre c'est un processus naturel
important pour la survie de la planète
il permet d'avoir une température
moyenne sur Terre les gaz à F ser
participent à ce processus
mais si le leur concentration augmente
dans l'atmosphère ça impacte forcément
le réchauffement climatique et nos
comportements alimentaires y contribu
tout à fait Floran c'est ça ça peut
paraître curieux mais nos habitudes
alimentaires ont bien un impact sur
l'environnement il faut savoir un repas
équivaut à environ 3 kg de CO2 pour se
rendre compte de ce qui crée cette ance
je me suis rendu dans les locaux
d'Igraine l'association a une animation
ludique autour d'un simple produit que
l'on mange tous le steak haché alors
actuellement l'itinéraire d'un steak
haché ça peut avoir jusqu'à neu étapes
la première c'est celle des engrais
produit parfois en russi qui crée du CO2
ou du protoxyde d'azote la deuxième
étape ce sont les champs de culture et
c'est mainot qui est chargé de mission à
l'association qui nous précise l'étape
les champs de culture qui sont encore
dans un autre pays en l'occurrence le
Brésil euh où là pour avoir de l'espace
il va falloir couper une partie de la
forêt pour pouvoir cultiver généralement
c'est ce qu'on cultive c'est des du
soja du soja qui est OGM donc un
organisme génétiquement
modifié ces cultures sont ensuite amené
au bétail qui s'en nourrit le bétail lui
est alors abattu transformé emballé
stocké ça se passe souvent en France
pour finir il sera mis en rayon dans les
grandes surfaces et finira dans nos
assiettes alors pour le steak haché de
la démonstration on a parlé de la Russie
du Brésil de la France ça explique à
chaque fois du transport que ce soit par
avion mais aussi par bate bateau et là
en fonction du mode de transport
l'impact diffère celui par avion c'est
environ 70 fois plus émetteur que par
bateau le transit routier lui c'est neu
fois plus émetteur que le ferroviaire et
trois fois plus que le fluvial dans ces
cas-là on parle de gaz fluoré ce sont
des gaz à effet de serre très puissant
que l'on retrouve aussi dans les
aérosols ou les solvants alors quelles
sont un peu les solutions que l'on peut
mettre en place ou qu'est-ce qui nous
est conseillé justement pour remédier à
cela il y en a plusieurs les plus
simples ou les plus rapides ce sont les
les il faut consommer des aliments de
saison qui sont aussi produits
localement on évite donc les tomates en
hiver ou même le kiwi en été un produit
hors saison transporté par voie aérienne
ça consomme 10 à 20 fois plus de pétrole
que le même fruits ou légumes produit
localement en saison on peut aussi
privilégier les circuits courts comme
les AMAP qu'on voit à l'image ce sont
les associations pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysane et là aussi c'est
Morinot qui va nous donner quelques
autres solutions il y a d'autres moyens
d'agir
euh par un commerce de proximité rien
que de relocaliser ça permet bah de de
réduire ses impacts négatifs pas
consommer plus que ce dont on a besoin
parce que là on a vu avec le le
l'emballage
euh on jette un emballage ok mais des
fois c'est le ST caché carrément qu'on
qu'on jette on peut aussi adapter notre
régime alimentaire manger moins de
viande par exemple parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'on consomme environ 240 kg de
viande par an si vous souhaitez en
découvrir plus l'association igraen
propose des animations autour de ce
sujet notamment l'itinéraire d'un stay
caché qu'on a découvert tout à l'heure
alors on l'aura bien compris il faut
faire attention à ce que l'on met dans
notre assiette on peut se faire plaisir
en mangeant mais tout en faisant un
petit geste justement pour la plè avant
de vous nous quitter vous avez un
rendez-vous annoncé Mélanie oui
rendez-vous mais cette fois on parle de
la de l'énergie et des bâtiments puisque
l'ALC 5qutin line l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie du climat organise un forum
élu citoyen le jeudi 11 février de 19h à
21h à la maison de car quti d'Orly Park
de la verrière la discussion portera
donc sur la thématique du bâtiment et
notamment comment améliorer la
performance des bâtiments du Sud des
Yvelines pour atteindre les objectifs de
réduction de consommation décidé à
l'horizon 2050 l'inscription est
recommandée peut-être l'objet d'une
future chronique merci beaucoup Mélanie
et de l'environnement nous passons
maintenant au cinéma depuis la rentrée
2015 les élèves du collège sainte- thérè
à rambouillé se sont mis au doublage de
bandeannonce de film encadré par un
animateur de l'atelier cinéma ils sont
une trentaine d'élèves a transformer
leur voix chaque semaine Mathilde
Lambert est allé suivre un de leurs
enregistrements
regardez les fans de Disney ont
peut-être reconnu cette réplique c'est
celle d'Olaf le célèbre bonhomme de
neige dans le dessin animé non moins
célèbre de la Reine des Neiges
aujourd'hui il est joué en version
originale par Baptiste je trouve que
c'est le plus marrant parce que donc il
est pas humain du coup on s'amuse il
faut lui faire une voix aue et en plus
il fait un peu n'importe quoi donc c'est
plus marrant comme lui ils sont une
trentaine d'élèves de l'établissement
sainte- Thérèse de Rambouillet à
s'entraîner pour arriver à ce résultat
un atelier doublage proposé d'abord en
français depuis la rentrée par un
animateur face au succès de cette
initiative anuk favar s joint à
l'aventure en janvier dans la langue de
Shakespeare je trouvais un intérêt
ludique et aussi pédagogique ça me
permet de travailler avec les élèves sur
tout ce qui est prononciation
intonation le jeu aussi et donc
ça leur permet de travailler leur
anglais également mais d'une autre
manière jusqu'à maintenant les élèves
adorent c'est vrai que c'est pas un
atelier courant puisquon a l'habitude de
voir dans les collèges des ateliers
théâtre ou des ateliers vidéo mais des
ateliers doublage c'est très très rare
et et du coup les élèves adorent se
mettre dans la peau de ces héros un
moyen de travailler tout en s'amusant
mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas pour
tout le monde l'établissement de
rambouiller est l'un des seuls du
territoire à proposé ce type d'atelier
et avant de refermer ce journal un mot
de culture la galerie d'Alfred devini de
voisin le Bretonneux accueille jusqu'au
19 février l'exposition douceurs
obscures et brumeuse un travail d'auteur
en noir et blanc qui réunit trois
photographes Claude chose Denis diclo et
Stéphane bretau regardez ce reportage de
Sephora Namani Mélanie poquet pour les
image apparu à la fin des années 1860 la
photocouleur est aujourd'hui la plus
répandue dans le 8e art le monocrome
continue néanmoins de séduire les
photographes qui trouvent dans ce style
une manière d'aller à l'essentiel de
l'expression de leur rart à l'image de
Stéphane bretau qui par le noir et blanc
illustre le ressenti d'un renoncement au
travers de son exposition the end le
noir et blanc apporte une neutralité que
je trouvais intéressante et également
une sorte d'intemporalité le noir et
blanc fait partie de l'histoire de la
photographie et on a même une
singularité par rapport au cinéma par
exemple ça porte un trait d'union entre
je crois le ressenti que peut partager
tous les les hommes sur terre à la fois
dans l'universitalité mais également
dans
laemporalité le noir et blanc permet de
mettre en valeur les formes et
l'éclairage du sujet d'un cliché cet
effet de contraste est souvent associé
au jeu de brouillard à la manière de
brassail ou encore comme le propose
Claude chose qui nous fait visiter les
jardins du château de Versailles avec sa
série manière de montrer les jardins de
Versailles la couleur n'aurait pas
apporté grand-chose et je voulais que
les gens se concentre sur le sujet plus
que sur le la couleur la couleur souvent
fait perdre l'intérêt du sujet donc
parce que il y a de belles couleurs et
cetera et cetera j'ai souhaité que le
brouillard m'apporte ce côté cotonneux
qui amène aussi les les regardant je
dirais à à un peu à imaginer ce qu'il en
est la galériie d'Alfred deinier réunie
jusqu'au 19 février le travail d'auteur
en noir et blanc de Stéphane bretau
claud chose et Denis duclo avec sa série
graphique in memoriam représentant un
système supposé ordonné qui a perdu le
contact avec la raison humaine
témoignage du Mémorial de l'Holocauste à
Berlin et c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi tout de suite
restez avec nous vous avez rendez-vous
avec Sephora Namani pour le magazine
culturel kiosque quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du 78 le journal je vous
souhaite donc une excellente
[Musique]
soirée